[Music]
good night for you yeah congratulations
thank you very much how do you feel I
mean this is like you're letting us all
in you're soaking it in you've been in
the moment I I'm really enjoying it I'm
just starting I got my parents here my
family my friends so we're all gonna
have a great night okay
so no official date tonight say it again
official date tonight my family okay I
just didn't know if there was a date all
right that's good that's your plus
several thrusts ever I like that all
right you had Maren Morris be part of
obviously this this collaboration come
and talk a little bit about that yeah
I'm super super excited that I was able
to make this song with Mayer and I've
went through a lot of singers and it
took a while to find somebody who's as
good as Maren and we're super excited
we're going to premiere the music video
tonight during the Grammys so it's a big
moment a lot of people talking about
that looking forward to the what
performances are you looking forward to
soon I want to see them all there's a
lot of surprises I heard and I'm excited
to see everybody is on stage I'm sure
they got some nice things planned you
enjoy the night with your family are